[Music]
this relationship is at the same time
the limit at which the self-contained
life of the family breaks up and goes
beyond itself the brother is the member
of the family and human spirit becomes
an individuality which turns towards
another sphere and passes over into the
consciousness of universality the
brother leaves this immediate elemental
and therefore strictly speaking negative
ethical life of the family in order to
acquire and produce the ethical life
that is conscious of itself and actual
this short paragraph number 458 is
bringing to a close the discussion of
the family that's been going on in the
last two paragraphs and talking about
this brother-sister relation that was
discussed primarily in the last
paragraph and now preparing for the role
that the brother is going to play and
further specifying the relations between
family and community or human and divine
laws so Hagel talks in terms of this
being a limit this relationship being a
limit between the self-contained life of
the family where the self-contained life
breaks up and goes beyond itself
extrudes itself you might say into the
larger environment of the community and
we could also look at this as a border
Grenda can have that that sense as well
so who is doing that we already have the
father going out there and doing the
same thing that now the brother is going
to be doing so here Hegel concentrates
on this younger man the brother the
member of the family says in whom spirit
becomes an individuality and
individuality not just within the family
but also visiter the larger community
and then this individuality turns
towards another sphere passes over into
the consciousness of universality this
is a very abstract way of talking and
what Hegel is is describing here is
essentially what we call coming-of-age
and going out to you know earn a living
to participate in the larger society
this happens by stages of course in most
cases but we see it in fairy tales where
the the hero goes out to you know into
the wide world to earn his living and as
often just cast out now Hegel is also
going to talk about this universality as
being a move from the negative ethical
life of the family and we'll talk about
why that's the case and further
paragraphs in order to acquire and
produce the ethical line
that is conscious of itself and actual
and that is to be found here in the
community
he passes from the divine law within
whose fear you lived over to human law
but the sister becomes or the wife
remains the head of the household in the
guardian of the divine law in this way
the two sexes overcome their merely
natural being and appear in their
ethical significance as diverse beings
who share between them the two
distinctions belonging to the ethical
substance these two universal beings of
the ethical world have they're for their
specific individuality and naturally
distinct soft consciousnesses because
the ethical spirit is the immediate
unity of the substance with
self-consciousness and immediacy which
appears therefore both from the side of
reality and a difference as the
existence of a natural difference it is
that side which in the shape of
individuality that is real to itself
showed itself in the notion of spiritual
being as an originally determinate
nature this moment loses the
indeterminate switch it's still a out
there and the contingent diversity of
dispositions and capacities it is now
the specific antithesis of the two sexes
whose natural existence acquires at the
same time the significance of their
ethical determination
paragraph 459 begins by talking a little
bit more about this this passing this
moving from one range of things or one
law to another on the part of the
brother but then it starts to elaborate
this fundamental difference or
distinction that's happening within
spirit within human beings and their
relations with each other and the
meanings that they find and this is
going to be tied in partly with sexual
difference but not reducible to merely
sexual difference enshrined say in
culture or in the continuance of
families so he says the the brother
passes from the divine law within whose
sphere he lived as he grew up within a
family to human law he becomes part of
the larger community but the sister
remains behind the sister becomes or the
wife remains and so here we're not
talking about roles you know sister and
wife brother or husband we're talking
about something that's going on
generationally right they remain the
head of the household
and the guardian of the divine law in a
certain sense they are deprived of a
possibility that is of going out and
becoming part of this larger community
finding themselves within the larger
community in relation to other
individuals in the larger community
governed by this human law but within
the household they reign supreme they
are able to further develop something
else you might say develop in a
different direction that we're going to
see discussed a bit more in the
paragraphs yet to come so this is going
to be identified with gender or sex
however you want to put it and I want to
get too bogged down into the many
different distinctions that people make
in the present about this although that
would be an interesting sub topic to
explore some other time so he goes on
and he says in this way the two sexes
overcome their merely natural being and
appear in their ethical significance
that is a key point to Hegel's treatment
of male and female or man and woman in
this section and indeed I would argue
throughout the entire work and in his
social theory more broadly the relation
between male and female or man and woman
you know male and females are like
understood in a generic sense man and
woman understood as specific
individuality as concrete people cannot
be reduced at least if it's going to
retain its spiritual significance merely
two sexual characteristics or even two
what it is that the larger culture or
the ongoing family says well this is man
and this is women and this is what they
do you know there's an ethical
significance here that Hegel wants to
highlight as always perhaps in danger of
being lost but very important to to
continually bring up so he says these
two Universal beings of the ethical
world notice that he doesn't say you
know the female is lost in particularity
universalities over here these are both
Universal the universal beings of the
ethical world have he says their
specific individuality in naturally
distinct self consciousness naturally
distinct self-consciousness is how are
they naturally distinct well in through
sexual difference and also through the
differentiation thereby of role which is
taking place in part through culture and
in part through cultures reverberations
within the family and then
reinterpretation within the matrix of
that much closer relationship right but
this is not you know the end of the
story this naturally distinct
self-consciousness is why not he goes on
and he says the ethical spirit is the
immediate unity of the substance with
self-conscious
again a very abstract way of talking
about this what do they mean by saying
something like ethical spirit is
immediate unity of the substance with
self consciousnesses when we have an
individual self consciousness that is
understanding itself in relation to
others and in an ethical way within we
might say an ethical framework it is in
a certain way United with and perhaps in
an uncomfortable manner with the ethical
substance with the mores with the
customs and laws right it could be the
law of the community it could be the
divine law so he says what we have here
is an immediacy right which appears both
from the side of reality and of
difference as the existence of a natural
difference so we begin with a natural
difference a natural distinction if we
want to say there there's some slipping
back and forth between these inter
Sheeta a splitting a a separation of man
and woman of male and female of sister
and brother going on with within this
and and notice that he says that this is
the appearing as the existence of a
natural difference that's something we
can take for granted now no no studies
saying that it appears both from reality
and from the difference that's a strange
way to talk about that isn't it what
does he is he just being you know extra
wordy is the you know engaging in a kind
of plain Azzam here no there's something
that's being thought out from within the
difference itself as well as the reality
the reality text the situation that
they're in
he goes on and he says it's that side
which in the shape of individuality that
is real to itself remember we looked at
this much earlier showed itself in the
notion of spiritual being as an
originally determined
at nature this is something we explored
previously the moment he says loses the
indeterminate nough switch it still have
therein the contingent diversity of
dispositions and capacities it's now the
specific antithesis instead of something
different of the two sexes of the of the
two genders each with their sphere each
with their roles each with their you
know own a role to play within this this
drama that that's playing out says they
acquire at the same time the
significance of their ethical
determination so it can't just be well
you know I'm a man because I have the
the phallus and you know everybody marks
me semiotic Lee as a man so I behave in
that way and I get certain privileges
and I maybe don't have to do things over
here in the household that I get to go
out here and if somebody else says well
I don't have that marker so I I'm stuck
here in the household but at least I get
to be in charge of that no it goes it
goes beyond that according to Hegel
there's something more going on there so
what is that well we still have to work
that out
the difference of the sexes and their
ethical content remains however in the
unity of the substance and its movement
is just the constant becoming of that
substance the husband is sent out by the
spirit of the family into the community
in which he finds his self conscious
being just as the family in this way
possesses in the community its substance
and enduring being so conversely the
community possesses in the family the
formal element of its actual existence
and in the divine law its power and
authentication neither of the two is by
itself absolutely valid human law
perceives in its living process from the
divine the law valid on earth from that
of another world the conscious from the
unconscious mediation from immediacy and
equally returns whence it came the power
of the nether world on the other hand
has its actual existence on earth
through consciousness it becomes
existence and activity
in paragraph 460 Hegel is now going to
add a little bit more about the
relationship between these two spheres
how they fit into each other and he
reminds us at the very beginning that
the difference of the sexes and their
ethical content he says remains in the
unity of the substance the unity of the
ethical substance the unity of spirit as
it is working itself out and so it says
and it's movement is just the constant
becoming of that substance this is
something that is worth emphasizing
because we're going to see this playing
itself out in just a few more paragraphs
when Hegel talks about justice it's very
important to see that any sort of
substance in order to remain dynamic is
going to have to have not just an
equilibrium but dis equilibria I'm going
on you can only have progress and
development or even a continuous you
know progression if there is something
that winds up slipping out of out of
gear you might say and so eagle is
sketching out for us in this paragraph
how these two are connected with each
other and he begins by talking in terms
kind of similar to what he did in two
paragraphs back
focusing on the male who leaves the
family doesn't you know become totally
disconnected from it but who exited who
crosses that border into the world of
the community the world of sort of self
conscious an actual spirit and so he
talks about the husband in this case no
longer the brother but the husband going
out into the community and as he puts it
being sent out by the spirit of the
family into the community in their
finding his self conscious being now why
does he go out into the community there
may be many reasons Hegel doesn't go
into them here but we could think for
example of economic reasons the need to
trade the need to sell where's the need
to labor for for wages in my
also be for a political representation
it might also be for other things the
ways in which families are connected to
each other going to visit another you
know another male head of a household in
a different family this whole notion of
gift exchanged in the past all of those
could be operative here in any case the
husband is going out and is finding it
self-conscious being in the the
community why because that's the locus
where that sort of thing happens now
Hegel sketches out two other things that
are going on first he talks about the
family itself not just the husband but
the family itself getting something out
of its relationship with the community
he says in this way the family has in
the community its substance and enduring
being it is the family for example of
this guy who people know on account of
him being out there in the community and
that he has children and he has a spouse
and he has mother and father as well and
you know whatever we want to talk about
in terms of the generations and the
structure of the family so the family is
gaining a sort of recognition in the
community through sending the father or
the other mail like the brother out into
the community is the community getting
anything out of it itself well you could
say hey with no families no community
we've already talked about this quite a
bit the family at least as understood in
most traditional social theories is a
basic unit that is a component of the
larger community the community is not
reducible to families but without
families no real community and Hegel is
saying something like that here but he's
adding something to that he says
conversely the community has in the
family the formal element of its actual
exist
now that's an interesting way to frame
it the formal element of its actual
existence right without there being
families again there is no community
right there is no existing community now
he also says in the divine law the
community finds its power it's coughed
and it's authentic Asian or if you like
it it's testing it its verification the
Zhi Hong without that without that that
aspect there's something that ends up
being missing you can't have four four
hagel at this point a community which is
going to be radically separated off from
what is happening in the family you
can't have a purely human law without
some sort of divine law that is that is
providing it with it it's a basis you
might say so he goes on and he says
neither of the two is by itself
absolutely valid human law proceeds in a
living process from the divine this
doesn't mean that human law proceeds
from the divine by receiving a divine
revelation and everyone saying oh okay
now we have to go from there
no you could say that it takes its cues
or it meets its limitations in the
divine law and that's the way it's going
to play out as we move and into these
these further sections right so he says
the law is valid on earth proceeds from
the that of the netherworld here's where
it gets really interesting to conscious
from the unconscious mediation from
immediacy and equally returns whence it
came
so he says a little bit further the
power of the netherworld has actual
existence on earth how through the
community through its eruption you might
say into the community through
consciousness it becomes existence and
activity and that means that unless it
does actually rise to the level of
consciousness which means that it has to
become part of the public it's not fully
what it is it's just sort of churning
away in a subterranean manner we love
these sorts of Casona k-- you know
metaphors for the unconscious ever since
the time of freud right but there's
something there's really something to
that so these two sides are going to be
connected with each other the conscious
- the unconscious and it's not going to
be possible for the the human to totally
take over in Contra distinction to the
divine
the universal ethical beings are then
the substance qual universal and the
substance quite an individual
consciousness their universal actuality
is the nation and the family well they
have their natural self an operative
individuality and man and woman in this
content of the ethical world we see
achieve those ends which the previous in
substantial forms of consciousness sent
themselves what reason apprehended only
is object has become self consciousness
and what the latter possessed only
within itself is now present as a true
objective reality what observation knew
is a given object in which the self had
no part is here a given custom but a
reality which is at the same time the
deed and work of the subject finding it
the individual who seeks the pleasure of
enjoying his individuality finds it in
the family and the necessity in which
that pleasure passes away is his own
self-consciousness as a citizen of his
nation or again it is in knowing that
the law of his own heart is the law of
all hearts in knowing the consciousness
of the self as the acknowledged
universal order it is virtue which
enjoys the fruits of its sacrifice which
brings about when it sets out to do that
is to bring forth the essence into the
light of day and its enjoyment is this
universal life finally consciousness of
the matter in hand itself find
satisfaction of the real substance which
contains and preserves in a positive
manner the abstract moments of that
empty category that substance has in the
ethical powers a genuine content that
takes the place of the insubstantial
commandment which sound reason wanted to
give in to know and thus it gets an
intrinsically determinate standard for
testing not the laws but what is done
Haaga was doing two main things in this
somewhat long ish paragraph 461 so first
he talks about the universal ethical
being that he has just been you know
sketching out in terms of the family and
the community the divine law the human
law how they intersect with each other
both of them need each other both of
them are the full expression of spirit
and yet are not completely you know the
entire show so he goes on any talks
about the universal ethical beings and
he makes another distinction here that's
very important so they are the substance
quod universal and the substance quat
and individual consciousness they are
present as as both and you might think
all the way back to the very first
substantive section of the phenomenology
where we explored the you know sense
certainty and we arrived at the
universal and then we moved into the
perception and the universal the thing
and its qualities all of this has been
leading up to to this we are now at the
point where we can see what he's calling
the Universal actuality of these
universal ethical beings as being the
family and the nation but there's also
an individual that's taking place that
is just as important and why is that so
important because the family and such
and the nation as such doesn't actually
do anything
we often talk in terms of these
Universal these these you know holes
that are composed of parts but it's the
parts that are actually doing the acting
the whole exists precisely because of
the reality of its parts so when we're
talking about the parts of things like a
family or a community we're talking
about human beings and those human
beings have natural selves in this case
we've been talking primarily about
distinctions between sexes right male
and female but they also have all sorts
of other particularities as well which
could come into play so he goes on and
he says in this content of the ethical
world we're going to see achieved those
ends which the previous in substantial
forms of consciousness set themselves
here's the second thing that's going on
what we went through in the reason
section particularly once we got out of
observing reason and we got into
practical reason right where the real
story is going on quite frankly what we
had were forms of consciousness Gestalt
--an right and those are now going to
find their realization here in what's
taking place in this spirit section so
we charge this out for us and notice
that there aren't really there there are
parallel isms going on but they're not
completely parallel he says we start out
with you know pleasure and necessity the
individual who seeks the pleasure of
enjoying his individuality find that
within the family and then the necessity
in which that pleasure fades passes away
is his own self-consciousness as a
citizen of the nation have to
subordinate the pleasure that one could
be taking just within the confines of
the family to some some larger task
right now if we back up a little bit in
this in his paragraph he says what
reason knew as a given object in which
the self had no part is here a given
custom but a reality that is at the same
time the deed and work of the subject
finding it this is again still the
subject the the the self consciousness
trying to work out for itself the very
meaning of its existence what about the
law of the heart
well you remember the law of the heart
went into the frenzy of self-conceit
that's not being talked about here
instead Hegel talks about moving from
the law of one's own heart to the law of
all hearts knowing that the law of his
own heart is the law of all hearts
knowing that the consciousness of the
self as the acknowledged universal order
so we don't have the frenzy that's going
on there the the tearing apart you know
the there isn't many talk about virtue
and he says it's virtue which enjoys the
fruits of its sacrifice you remember
that in the virtue and the way of the
world section virtue did not enjoy the
fruits of it sacrifice instead what
happened is virtue is revealed as
somewhat of a sham as not really able to
take on the way of the world that it
ought to have been able to address so
perhaps what we're seeing here is a
recuperation and a you know context
providing for these three dynamics then
Hegel goes on and he talks about you
know what ended up being the key thing
for the last section of reason from the
spiritual animal kingdom on the matter
in hand right or the you know the heart
of the matter it was also how it was
translated those occas ELPS i've been
translating it as the project right and
what he says here is that instead of
having something that turns out to be
essentially empty right the
consciousness of the matter in hand find
satisfaction we're in the real substance
which contains and preserves in a
positive manner the abstract moments of
that empty category what it was reaching
for through all those dynamics and was
they unable to find particularly in the
last two things in giving itself laws
and testing those laws turns out not to
be what it was really all about what
it's about now is the real ethical
substance so he says that substance has
in the ethical powers what are the
ethical powers again family
nation woman-man has in these a genuine
content that takes the place of the in
substantial Commandments which sound
reason wanted to give and know so what
do we conclude here it gets an
intrinsically determinate standard for
testing not the laws but what is done
what what is what is done what is done
are the customs that are being
replicated over and over again from
generation to generation and the
innovations that are also taking place
in the relations between people
discovering who they are not just by
themselves but engaged with others in
the larger ethical sphere of the nation
or the community however we want to
frame it so all of these previous stages
they were indeed something that was at
that stage something real something
determinant we can read them into
people's lives and historical periods
but they also had a greater meaning and
greater purpose which is now being
realized here as they are sublated
alcohol burned into these ethical beings
of this section
you